I know you're all probably thinking how
do I always stay so positive I'm not
always happy sometimes I'm sad too and
that's okay it's okay to be sad just
know that this too shall pass your crush
finally text you what well first you
should panic don't panic make a plan
call your BFF speak to your therapist
call a conference with United pastry
nation
[Music]
okay I did it perfect you do Oh weird
it's so important to find a partner who
really loves and accepts you for who you
truly are
[Music]
uh ugh I don't know what to do with my
life I don't know what job I want and I
don't know where I want to live and what
if no one ever likes me and I never fall
in love and what is oh it's me
the good advice cupcake and I'm here to
let you know that it'll all be okay but
it's okay to not know what you want to
do with your life you don't have to
worry about it now you have your whole
life ahead of you and it'll all work
itself out anyway it's me good advice
cupcake I get lots of energy for my
friends that's because I'm yeah sure
sometimes cookie I've got a great idea
why don't you do advice today hey it's
me the cookie sometimes people need time
to recharge after being around their
friends but if that's you don't know
don't worry too much okay because your
friends still love you how's that that
was exhausting let's go take a nap
together separately together
[Music]
you